aumenta la presión para que el Primer
Ministro Richie sunak haga una nueva
oferta que permita levantar el paro de
los trabajadores de la salud que tendrá
un gran impacto sin duda en el sistema
Público de salud del país eneches la
huelga de hoy se considera histórica
porque por primera vez participan
enfermeras y trabajadores de las
ambulancias como conductores y
paramédicos la huelga de hoy es grande
participan más de 73 hospitales en toda
Inglaterra lo que se traduce en miles de
enfermeras y en Diez mil trabajadores de
las ambulancias esa presión a Richi es
una llega adicional porque los gobiernos
regionales de Escocia ilegales lograron
avanzar en las negociaciones con las
enfermeras y por ello no se han sumado a
las huelgas 24 hablamos con Andrea
García ella es española ha sido
enfermera de leneche es por nueve años y
nos cuenta las razones por las que hoy
se suma a protesta Pues estamos aquí
haciendo la huelga pues como bien sabéis
porque queremos Un aumento de sueldo
pero no solamente por el aumento de
sueldo sino también porque las
condiciones de trabajo que tenemos son
bastante pésimas Y nefastas estamos muy
cortos de personal
trabajamos sobre muchísima presión y la
verdad que nos gustaría que también el
gobierno apoyase y ayudarse a la nh esa
que pudiese contratar más enfermera hay
muchas vacantes de enfermería Pero la
realidad es que seguimos muy cortos de
personal el gobierno asegura que por la
huelga de las enfermeras solo hoy se han
cancelado 50.000 operaciones en toda
Inglaterra pero esta situación lejos de
tener un luz verde de tener una solución
a la vista se va a empeorar porque toda
esta semana va a haber huelgas de
diferentes especialidades del Sistema
Nacional de salud que hace años está en
cuidados intensivos pero pone mucha más
presión política al Primer Ministro para
que negocie no solamente con el sistema
con los trabajadores a través del
sistema de salud sino con otros sectores
que mantienen al país prácticamente en
una huelga general